[Musique]
aujourd'hui on laisse croire que la
voiture électrique puisse se substituer
à la totalité de la mobilité
alors qu'en fait il n'a pas du tout les
capacités minières les capacités
industrielles
il faut rappeler quand même que sur la
terre il ya 2 milliards de voitures en
circulation
donc c'est pas son descendant temps
qu'on va réussir à complètement
substitut espère par la motricité
électrique donc du coup la question
n'est pas tellement de savoir si on est
pour ou contre si c'est très bien ou pas
bien
la question c'est de savoir qu'un
appartement ou n'aura que quelques
pourcents peut-être dans un avis à
vannes 1-1 intervenir on sera peut-être
à 10 20 39 cents la question c'est
quelle est la mobilité que l'on va
substituer par la rouille par des
véhicules électriques
est-ce que ça va s'adresser à des choses
qui sont plus ou moins efficaces en
terme de ce que dessous de ce qu'on
attend voilà donc à la question c'est
quelles sont les véhicules que l'on va
substituer en furie qu on ne voit qu une
des faces de la voiture électrique c'est
à dire la personne qui monte dedans et
puis qui roule ça fait pas de bruit ne
se pose pas la question d'où vient
l'électricité et surtout où on l'a
stocks
et finalement quand on décortique petit
à petit toutes ces machines on
s'aperçoit que la batterie c'est
l'aspect clé de la voiture c'est le
coeur de la voiture et cette batterie
aujourd'hui il suffit de faire des
multiplications pour sa part ce soir
pour fabriquer ces boîtes prix il faut
des éléments qui sont des composés
minéraux qui proviennent de mines etc
donc ça veut dire qu'il ya derrière
toute une industrie qui va entre
parenthèses détruire d'une 7900 la
planète et ça on oublie de le dire quand
on fait quelque chose et qu'on veut
faire de l'écologie faut partir du début
est allé jusqu'à la fin
c'est à dire s'il faut les matériaux
comment on les fait comme on les recycle
ecsta est à mon avis la voiture
électrique on présente que l'aspect tout
à feu en positif alors qu'on ne voit pas
du tout les côtés noir de l'écologie de
cette voiture
si vous supposez que dans 20 ans tout va
être électrique vous pouvez dire bon jeu
peut commencer par les véhicules
ostentatoire des énormes et suivait des
bolides c'est pas grave ça paie
recollera donc ils sont tous sera
concerné donc les priorités
si on veut traiter la question de la
qualité de l'air avec un homme de
batterie qui serait relativement limité
ça serait d'abord d'adresser les deux
roues des véhicules intensif urbain de
logistique par exemple et aussi les bus
et pas du tout de traiter en premier les
bolides et les gros suv si vous voulez
donc là la crainte comme moi je vois
c'est que dans quelques années on se
réveille avec un électrique gates tout
simplement
c'est à dire une situation dans laquelle
on aura constaté qu'on aura gaspillé en
fait l'affectation des batteries vers
des usages qui ne sont pas du tout
prioritaire ni pour traiter la qualité
de l'air nous pour améliorer la
les émissions de gaz à effet de serre du
parc automobile quand on veut prévoir
l'avenir à 20 ans ou à 50 ans deux
nations il vaut mieux pas gaspiller la
vôtre l'argent et je m'aperçois dans le
programme ce qu'on appelle la
programmation pluriannuelle de
l'électricité actuelle c'est un
gaspillage potentiel absolument
hallucinant on se lance dans des
procédés qui ne sont pas rentables donc
on subventionne accès terrestres tout ça
pour eux j'allais lui ni écologique est
une espèce d'écologie idéalisé est en
réalité bien sûr les écologistes de base
sont des gens tout à fait j'allais dire
honnête compétent etc
mais en dessus de ça il ya des gens qui
en profitent et eux ce qu'ils voient
c'est du marketing et vous avez des
instruits des industriels qui sont jetés
sur ces procédés sur ces choses pour
faire de l'argent
[Musique]
déjà avant qu'elle existe la voiture
électrique les nouvelles énergies
renouvelables il faut bien constater
qu'elles sont en échec en échec au
niveau européen français européen
mondial simplement parce qu'elles ne
réussissent pas sur leur but premier
était de substituts des énergies
fossiles et dans le cas particulier de
la france
éventuellement aussi subtile nucléaire
lorsque l'on constate depuis maintenant
plusieurs décennies
c'est que les énergies renouvelables en
fait elles s'additionnent et c'est d'ici
au nord-ouest ne se substitue pas
pourquoi parce qu'on n'arrive pas à
réduire en fait globalement la
consommation électrique
alors si en plus on électrifie des
moyens de transport qui donc vont
augmenter encore la demande
je dire mais bon on va on va encore
s'éloigner de la substitution que l'on
recherche c'est pour ça qu effectivement
à marche forcée en augmentant fortement
la demande électrique particulièrement
en france on va se retrouver dans un
dilemme qui est de dire on ne peut pas
faire autrement que de construire des
réacteurs
parce qu'on a beau planter des éoliennes
avec les problèmes que ça soulève il
faudrait en planter des quantités
énormes pour réussir un à substituer ce
qu'on voulait des énergies fossiles et
en plus et en plus permettre un usage
supplémentaires l'hydrogène par dessus
ça l'hydrogène affrontement qui est
quand même moins bon que que de que
d'aller utiliser des batteries et ce
problème de rentrer dans la conséquence
c'est que sa demande en hameaux encore
plus d'électricité pour exactement le
même mouvement dans l'arrivée
donc c'est vrai que croit aussi qu'on va
développer à marche forcée l'hydrogène
c'est la porte ouverte à une demande
extraordinaire électrique qui ne pourra
effectivement elle satisfaire plupart
des moyens très massif la voiture
électrique c'est la m c'est le meilleur
défenseur de l'énergie nucléaire il
faudra de l'électricité alors tous les
autres moyens actuels je suis pas un pro
nucléaire mais je constate que les
écologistes font exactement tout ce
qu'il faut pour développer ce genre
d'industrie à terme 1 donc quand on
parle d'hydrogène là aussi c'est encore
un leurre l'hydrogène actuelle la
meilleure façon de l'obtenir c'est le
pétrole et il n'y a pas de procès des
concurrents de du craquage du pétrole
aujourd'hui pour produire de l'hydrogène